une nouvelle saison débute pour les
lionnes du paris 92 l'effectif désormais
au complet été officiellement présentée
à l'aube du premier match il aura pour
objectif de finir sur le podium après
avoir terminé dans le top-5 line
dernière les ambitions monde d'année en
année la leçon de plus en plus forte on
va maintenant commencer à aviser avisés
des titres tous les ans peut-être pas
forcément cette année mais en tout cas
on s'y prépare dans son effectif le club
pourra compter sur sa capitaine
yvelinoise deborah la source à 21 ans la
handballeuse originaire de maisons
laffitte est au club depuis sept ans
paris 92 comptera également dans ses
rangs une championne olympique en titre
avec laura flippes l'une des meilleures
joueuses françaises à tokyo cet été
forcément j'ai envie de faire une belle
saison j'ai envie d'aider l'équipe au
maximum et qu'on en fasse de bons
résultats cette saison je pense que ça
change beaucoup pour elle mais c'est
vrai que pour nous on est très fier très
contente pour elle mais ça reste une
aventure de sélection et non en club
donc on espère justement gagner des
titres avec elle au total le club pourra
compter sur quatorze joueuses
professionnelles et des jeunes du centre
de formation un effectif plus étoffé que
les dernières années ça me permet de
pouvoir amener certaines josette fraîche
dans les moments importants du match ça
me permet également de diversifier les
formes de jeu donc effectivement pour un
coach c'est très intéressant d'avoir
autant d'options premier match ce
mercredi 8 septembre pour les lionnes
contre chambre et la rencontre est
programmée à 20h au palais des sports
d'issy les moulineaux
[Applaudissements]